this week we've got suspicious objects
date pamphlets and real extra estate but
for our first story
it's a suspicious object in the sky so
this is on the streets on the streets
are you at follow Street any other
guesses it's not like the Boston bombing
right so we just left the backpack and
you're like [ __ ]
this one's light hearted is it hidden
camera no I do have a photo of this
object I'm just silicon dildo penis
shaped I knew actually silicon dildo I
don't think you on a carpool lane know
what yeah it was like a big flaccid
dildo just like on a car hood like I was
driving on a carpool lane and then like
I didn't recognize it
it was traffic so it was kind of slow so
you gotta examine it so I got to see you
know like oh my god that's a big pink
flesh dildo just laying there on the
carpool lane and I'm like someone must
have threw it out the window
it was big it was like that yeah even
better it's not too small
damn okay so this object was this took
place in Chicago they closed down on the
roller Street
those are skateboard wheels that's so
funny
a ravioli can wear D I just love that
[ __ ] yeah with like chopsticks dude
that's dough why would they shut down a
street for that crackhead invention yeah
is it whether like pickle hope it's
attached to it there was nothing else
attached to it that would make hoes on
the freeway no this was like on a
downtown street they closed the hole my
god look like a bomb yeah so people
thought that it was a suspicious oh my
god the whole street for a Spanish chef
boyardee hey that's pretty safe fighters
precinct
so it turns out that this was a class
project like a that's what it looked
like an engineering project or something
it's a car
prototype for a design class at this
local university and the student this 19
year old man definitely failed he was
actually ticketed for disorderly conduct
and breach of peace so he put the his
design in the street and he wanted to
take a photo of it because it's like a
car and when he did that people were
like what is that oh my god grab it I
don't know yeah I think you should have
not take it cause he's a idiot
you probably just got freaked out he's
like really socially awkward when
everybody freaked out he just freaked
out something like that but I'm pretty
sure he failed his class of with or
without the citation because I think
they're like [ __ ] yeah it's pretty bad I
could have done that and I didn't even
go to engineering school I know the
design class well he failed
I could have designed something better
than that yeah I thought that was like
elementary school work I know I know
what if it just looks like garbage but
it's like remote control and everything
oh those rubber bands masking tape
holding it together project like you
have to use garbage to make a far is
that even in that case household items
maybe yeah but dude that is the
shittiest car you know what though if I
use rubber bands f7z that was like if
that was life-size I would like to drive
that dude that straight up a crackheads
car dude there's a rubber band for
wheels at a chef boyardee cab
that is a crackheads [ __ ] superhero
[ __ ] it doesn't that remind you of like
those cartoons when they had donuts on
the wheels and they would use a can and
we're yeah yeah we'll see now someone's
gonna make a bomb that looks like that
and everyone was gonna go oh we saw that
before I wonder how much damage that
sighs bomb okay no it's pretty small Oh
bombs can be small right Bart oh I think
so why I used to love those rabbit
grenades can be small right and like
when they're in the ground and they're
like a minefield aren't they small I
could mine yeah and like those bombs in
like the movies where they're attached
to people they're like pretty small I
was watching a video of [ __ ] grenades
right you know there's no fire that
comes from grenades all fired it it just
goes
shrapnel yeah I had no [ __ ] idea
vaporizes whatever's around it but
there's no like fire yes shrapnel it's
like so does the concussion so the force
around it it creates a force so even if
there were no like metal shrapnel around
it give them blown it yeah if you have
something if you have this tissue paper
just getting paper eyes because the
concussive force is there gas are there
yeah what causes that I don't know
gunpowder yeah well because in like in
Umbrella Academy
remember when number 5 oh yeah you like
I did you watch umbrella can but you
can't watch Game of Thrones
it's so [ __ ] good TV watch umbrella
kid destroys the place he throws a
grenade and it's fire that's once a so
every time I see movie magic yeah that's
why I'm blown away - no pun intended pun
intended better hit it gunshots and
movies are actually a lot more cooler
than in real life even like dark rooms
where they're like they're doing like
photos and stuff they always have like a
red light yeah but that's also for
movies well I've been at dark rooms back
and uh well the way they wrote it it's
like very small yeah you can't like if
you're if you're taking out like film it
has to be pitch black I always liked it
in film when they have a car scene at
night and that's clearly this under like
that coming from when you shoot at a car
engine and the whole car blows up blows
up oh yeah that's right yeah that
grenade thing threw me off though my
whole world was shattered how'd you find
out I was just looking up grenades I was
it's like one of those things when
you're on late at night and you just go
through this black hole and then I was
watching it was something about gun
shooting they left to like whatever like
all this like artillery [ __ ] but they
were throwing the grenade [ __ ] and there
was no flame and I didn't know that so I
google it if there's a flame in training
it's one of the scariest things so like
we do you get to use live grenade by one
live grenade and then there's like a
cinderblock wall you gotta go up to it
you hit it with your shoulder and you
throw it over but then so usually when
you have a chance to throw something you
just have the complete confidence but
with this one you know if it slips out
every hand I gave you have butterfingers
then you're like
oh [ __ ] you thinking about it your palm
start getting sweaty and then you're
also thinking what if I do something
stupid and I [ __ ] loop it and it goes
right next to the senator baucus on all
the way over so all these things just
start going in your head yeah have you
seen those videos where people [ __ ]
throw one and then it [ __ ] flies back
where they [ __ ] up and then all the guys
are like holy [ __ ] no it's just whenever
the the FEMA alesis so I don't know
maybe like five or five ten seconds
maybe damn you there's two safeties on
it there's the lever did you ever see
anyone get hurt
no do some people might be [ __ ] would
they put superglue on yours are you
supposed to hold on to the lever and
throw it with the lever or do you
release the lever and then throw it you
want to let go of the lever and throw at
the same time so you're just throwing it
the whole thing
wait same time please we pull the
panel's yeah and knots activate it
because they're now as soon as the lever
detaches it's gonna blow so you keeper
you clamp onto the levers oh my gosh
yeah I knew that part of the movie
sometimes I'll take the pin out and
they're forcing the victim tonight hold
on to it oh yeah
anyway let's move on the Friday night
story a comedian gave her family these
informational pamphlets or their family
vacation Oh Margaret Cho
Mary Beth Barone this is what she looks
like she's a bot owning do you know that
comedian no nope there's a lot of
comedians they're not no animal yeah
there's millions even on Netflix I'm
just like all these dumb communities
days yeah so she gave these out it said
would you like to read me I'm not a
comedian I'm going on a date while we're
on vacation
here's everything you don't actually
need to know but that will definitely
ask wait what I said I'm going on a date
well we're on vacation please remain
calm frequently asked questions who is
this guy my friend Sarah's brother where
did you meet him at the wedding in North
Carolina weren't you sick yeah I was how
old is he he's 31 where does he live
Miami what does he do in Miami he works
respond to fire frequently asked
questions continued
are you dating no we're just getting to
know each other how far is the drive an
hour I think I thought you had a show
tonight I canceled because I'd rather do
this
what is the parking situation in Miami
I'm not sure but it's gonna be okay
more questions don't don't
and says fun fact he's trying well with
the little dog on the with the ball in
his mouth oh cool
wait who is this for her parents her
family so she tweeted this out and she
was saying that her family liked her
immediate family and extended family
members we're all gonna go to a vacation
near Miami which is where the guy she
was gonna go on a date with lives and so
she was traveling with about 20 to 30
family memories yeah why would you bring
someone you just kind of met to a family
bring them she's gonna date gonna take
in Miami they were going to Miami and
she's gonna go on a date with him yeah
cuz she's based in New York oh so she's
gonna bail on her family go on a date
with him well yes she actually had a
show that was one of the questions and
the frequently asked questions you'd be
a family member that's where she made
these tablets so she's saying that her
family is just like super super super
nosy and she knew that they were gonna
be asking a million questions as family
should be yeah that's what family's
supposed to do like how can I borrow the
car and attend to other questions so she
thought she need to do all that she'd
been like gone I guess some dick that's
all she needed to say but then they were
gonna ask her like with who is this guy
how old was the damn where is the dick
livin is she old enough to get some dick
well she looks as she comes from a
Latino family oh yeah there's a casino
called casino Barone well I mean they
seem Mexican to me so I feel like it's
kind of the same where they're gonna ask
a million questions cuz they're so
involved and there's no way you can be
like I'm just getting Italians are very
much family-oriented that's true there's
no such thing as mind your own business
in Japanese culture either there's no
such thing exactly
you out of my kid do my mom what time
was about to kick my ass since the first
time I set up to her when I had braces I
wanted to work like face to face no no
no no damn I'm not trying to fight all
the time that's my dad one time oh
what I know I should've put him stepping
up feels they didn't work out so this is
me like putting my foot down so I wanted
I would get rubber bands on my bracelet
yeah I wanted to go black and yellow
she's like why did you do that it looks
like you know if she's talking [ __ ] I'm
like cuz it's my mouth can I was like
yeah that's all crazy and my mom's like
walk back that's my mouth [ __ ]
no I know well and she was like what the
[ __ ] did you just send I was like oh my
god I didn't say anything what did she
do
yeah yeah all of a sudden she knew kung
fu and she I mean she did always new
construction you heard me [ __ ]
lesbian like you can't even make your
own decisions like standing up to my
parents man when I was younger person
when you can't do [ __ ] it's so dumb cuz
you live in their house yeah stand up
Tim is one day when they don't have
control over you one time I told my dad
that he shouldn't abuse me dude he
abused because of that statement was
unreal United me like I remember this
moment too I might have mentioned it
before but he was like basically like I
got into my head the only when you see
that was like black and white
commercials like I specifically remember
this commercial of this kid about to get
hit and the giggles no dad and it freeze
frames yeah this [ __ ] right
so I was like oh [ __ ] I don't have to
take it and so my dad I don't remember
what it was I told my mom that my mom's
like that's for white people she's like
Asians take it I'm like I told my dad I
was like he was beating my ass I stopped
it was like no I was like that's child
abuse he died [ __ ] you thought he
stopped he goes okay he walks out I was
like what the [ __ ] this guy goes I did
it work he comes back he has a lead pipe
in his hand he goes swings full force I
[ __ ] duck and he smashes my shelf
behind me and he goes that's child
[Laughter]
good who's really good and did my mom
cuz there she goes I don't know your
childhood is traumatizing me right now
but I was like that's so dumb why would
you say that I don't know I was smart
and just sat in my room just scared
shitless although shitty thank you but
now you know the difference yeah there's
a big difference which I'll use in the
other stuff my child abuse like me yeah
that was like what the [ __ ] I got your
older brother you die whatever dude I
try to tell my dad to stop abusing me
and then he beat my ass because I
accused him of abuse
[Laughter]
so this real-estate agency they they
created this really elaborate crazy-ass
video to show off a property in
Australia and I'm gonna show you guys
oh we know those Aussies it's a
two-minute video but it's shortened down
to one I like those really they have
impeccable taste oh yeah oh wow that's
an interesting property Pam made up
listen it looks like surrender oh it's
Joel's old car oh no it's real
hey you driving on the wrong side
that's a Japanese car the neighborhood
wasn't good too long I don't like those
tiles dogs that's a good shot Oh get a
good feel I don't like that pay pot
that's MTV crib penny I think that sex
yeah yeah that's a nice house they could
have done without the people so this
went viral because of how extra yeah
it's pretty extra and I just don't like
these modern like I don't know I feel
like that Styles gonna get old real
quick cuz like in the 80s they did that
and that [ __ ] got old real fun ice cube
blocks oh yeah well you can't really see
through but you kind of can those are so
popular that was like the epitome of
rich just show off the property to get
eyeballs on the property so if you get
sold and so the I guess I worked if I
went viral for sure dude doesn't want to
be a real estate he wants to be a editor
he wants to be a video editor he wants
to make dance music video I definitely
don't like home like that
it seems very sterile it just does it
feel like you walk in there and you can
realize it seems like you're a rich dude
that's been single for so long yes you
made all your money but you're you're
lonely it's the only way I could get
[ __ ] what I have to have square
everywhere like maybe you got a lot of
[ __ ] you but like you you never have
real love
that's who lives there it's like the
couple that tries to appear rich but
they're not really rich yeah yeah I
don't like new money feel I am but it I
don't know it doesn't to me doesn't
scream luxury what it screams is like
it's a luxury car but the lowest model
especially in the neighborhood did you
see it yeah that's exactly what regular
houses and the like
yeah it's it's like regular homes and
then they knocked it down they remodeled
it that's that's what they didn't if you
look at the back yard everything is like
the rich stuff but the smaller version
that an infinity pool but the really
small one I live in a Armenian
neighborhood and you know what that that
was like how is in it and they would
take like it was it'd be like a two
bedroom house but they would make it
with like a little like a driveway you
know like rich like huge mansions have
those driveways there yeah you shape
they would make it but it was like super
tight super small like barely fit one
card with the tiny little fountain turn
just to like computer so it's a parking
lot for Power Wheels and go-karts huh
and I would be like there'd be like
infinities and Mercedes and all kinds of
crazy cards like all down the street and
it's all for this one house it was like
a two-bedroom house but it was like all
the rich things but like not in like a
neighborhood that's my good affluent
neighborhood yeah so for this video
someone put the Dirty Dancing soundtrack
in the background and it actually
matches it pretty perfect
it's pretty funny oh hell yeah it's way
better all right our Baba
I like that glowing ceiling No
oh yeah
ah seed I literally thought you might
occur over this song would have been way
better way better that's perfect and who
walks into a home like that
nobody maybe when your house is ballin
you walk in like oh maybe huh I'm so
[ __ ] rich they're just trying to
replicate that feeling of when you
bought a new house wait what the bottom
oh if this is the backyards that infest
a mini infinity wall oh it's like a pool
infinity pool yeah the pool most
Finiti but it has like a hallway that's
really cool oh that pool and then like a
little regular pool I didn't see that
part
yeah well that's minute videos they
should just focus on this part oh it
goes indoor that's pretty awesome it's
not good or indoor but it goes like
along the what look at it show this
cousin oh that's really cool that went
indoors I'll be like sold yeah imagine
like a doggie door but for the pool ya
know you guys love the [ __ ] house
[Laughter]
branding people they were like well I
mean no because so many people are
making fun of it and they were just like
hey the whole point is to get eyeballs
on the property and the more eyeballs
you get the more likely it's gonna get
sold so we're all for it
I follow a bunch of real estate agents
and they make like epic videos but the
dancing even though it's cheesiest [ __ ]
it does separate it cuz it now you're
like what the [ __ ] yeah cuz they all
look the same it's like a wedding video
they all look almost exactly the same we
should make [ __ ] me do butter that
should be the people are like oh yeah we
bought the house
you know what the dancers then we bought
that we live there I would just have a
video like in the bedroom there's like a
couple [ __ ] you could imagine
yourself [ __ ] right there and there's
like one where they start fighting in a
living room
and it's making the kids in one of the
bedroom and it's like every time it
rotates it's them
you know to me yeah so you go to the
front envision your how your life in you
and then like the neighbors come in and
they're asking for sugar and you're
cursing them out to me get the [ __ ] off
your property you know the bathroom and
Dragunov yeah in the black mayor episode
where she goes in visits the model oh
yeah then they had like a hologram of
like what your life could be like basic
we're gonna be perfect the guy the
husband like making her dinner and stuff
and there's like one scene where the
husband's getting [ __ ] in the ass by
another guy in the way what's going on
could be you
[Music]